uber now lets you choose to see your bad
reviews
is your cab behavior highly rated or are
you like jesse waters and hated
[Laughter]
and while barfing in the back of uber
cars drop your rating to zero stars it's
a question for everyone going anywhere
with cat
uber has added an additional feature to
its ride-sharing app allowing users to
see a breakdown of the star ratings
they've received from their drivers uber
says they hope the new information will
help you stop being an
speaking of turns out new york city has
the lowest average rider rating in the
country maybe because so many trips are
from paroled felons
to improve your score uber recommends
being on time not making a mess and
don't eat boiled cabbage unless you plan
to share
janice i bet you have a flawless score
don't you do we have your score
i don't i don't go anywhere you don't go
anywhere no so the score that i have is
i guess it's okay i gave it to the
purdue there it is you guys are uh
that's a good score four point nine but
who gave me a one oh you know who gave
me a one nobody i'm assuming
yes cuomo cousin one of his cousins it
was it might have been chris cuomo doing
uber no he's got to work somehow you
were driven by chris cuomo and he looked
in the rear view and he gave you but he
still only gave he gave you a two-star
right yeah that's nice oh man
yeah
can you go back and see who gave you the
two star i don't think so i tried
no wait let me get you two are you do
you take uber a lot yeah
let's see how you did on this this is
fun this is like playing poker this
ruined my weekend
that's still not bad that's not that's
people that's nothing that's nothing
that's nothing um i'm around there let's
do mine because i'm gonna i'm saving the
worst for last
uh let's take a look at this crap okay
so i have 4.82 but i didn't really have
zero one stars how because look at how
many how many rides i've had that's why
i take it i have a driver right you
don't go anywhere you're the driver no i
don't take the subway
i'm never in a he's on the subway with
joy behar yeah i'm almost never in a car
drunk unless i'm going somewhere but
when i'm coming home i'm never drunk
because i never go home are you my point
are you a chatty oh it depends it
depends if i know the driver like if
it's jeeves
uh we'll have a long discussion tyrus uh
i'm i'm calling foul on this one because
yeah
uh
cause they have to do extra stuff for me
and i know
i know all how many one stars i got 12.
geez and i know what they are from
because i always tell them they have to
push the seat forward
and several times the car's been too
small and be like bruh they're saying xl
you know what i'm saying so i know
exactly what you're saying yeah and i've
had to send them away because the car's
too small that is a problem that i will
never have no when you tell them to move
the seat up and they get mad you can see
them
they go around and then it goes really
slow and they have to get back around
and get back in and then i know that
it's a it's going to be bad but so what
was that they're 12 but that was still a
high you had still i had a bunch of
fives i just know whenever i told
someone to adjust the seat they they
have to get up and go around yeah they
don't like to get out of their seat
because then their big gulp is here
their big league chew giant backpack
with stuff in it yes exactly
totally yeah exactly what now um so i
guess we should just
get to the ugly ugliness of this that um
let's see what you got
so damn
25 stars
look i'm not for everyone
and
it turns out that a lot of the people
for whom i am not just happen to drive
for
uber i think that should be the title of
your book it's true okay i have 4.9
stars on lift so i don't know like what
am i doing wrong i don't know you know
what's interesting not wearing a
seatbelt 25 people are like absolutely
not yes out of five people they see me
absolutely not yep you can't get a zero
though right no or i probably would have
50. yeah
i love that like we
the customer are being judged by what we
i guess you would call the servant even
though it's not it is a kind of a
servant what if you monetize i always
give them five stars so like it's not
fair i'm not getting what i put in out
of that but think about this think about
this what if you monetize good behavior
like so like so so what uber should be
doing right now is they should be going
okay if you have
a four anything above a 4.8 gets 10 off
their rides
that is how you and what if that spread
so that if you're at starbucks now this
is the cha this is china china social
entire life it would ruin him
this is how you cure
but i'm not
i'm a delight 25 people would disagree
25 people
who happen to drive for yeah they're not
apparently they're not 25 people i'm
they're not their demographic that's not
not for everyone up next a picture meant
to excite won't have them swiping right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else